ça tombe bien et à toutes les personnes
3 c'est bon c'est à côté
la déflation persiste veut pas c'est
quoi ça rires il accumule elma la
sorbonne à mon avis n'est pas dans un
ghetto est alors y'a pas une tare et à
la fac c'est là que j'ai rencontré son
père louis bout de son voyage à temps
mais maman y'a pas la sauce a manqué
cette rentrée samedi je trouve que vous
répondez pas si quelqu'un vous pendant
l'effort mais le titre avait coutume un
tel contrat
[Musique]
oui je m'appelle promis on vous appelle
mais oui ça déboule s agit de vouloir
couple
allez bisous mais oui à ce jour aux
appels
c
m
[Musique]
quand j'ai encore trois ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
/
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc que je sais que c'est un bien
atypique mais très convoité parce que
voyez beaucoup de luminosité pas de
vis-à-vis exposition plein sud
la chambre bureau la salle de bain avec
la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque ses
traits plus âge mais du coup on mange
dans la baignoire
ouais bah ça se fait plus en plus sa
toilette il n'y a pas de toilettes je
suis bien sûr elles sont juste en face
sur le palier je vais prendre votre
dossier tout de suite ce que vous avez
eue il ya pas mal de moments je pense
qu'il faut faire les thèmes non on va
vous l'envoyez attendez vous n'avez pas
au dossier avec vous c'est inutile
d'attendre si vous n'avez pas un dossier
complet donc celle-ci dernière j'ai de
belles oppositions les plus atypiques
par exemple quand tu arrives tu appelles
ton avis pourquoi je suis venu à paris
pour changer de vie je veux garantir je
veux du rêve
la chambre le bureau la salle de bain
avec la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque
mais du coup on mange dans la baignoire
ben ça se fait de plus en plus on va pas
habiter avec wagner chaleurs tu l'aimés
150 mètres carrés on trouvera jamais vu
qu'est ce qu'il fait là je ne raconterai
mais nouveau coloc sa part de recraqué
c'est sa maman
moi je m'en fous de lui un sélecteur
nexon j'ai réfléchi ça va c'est pas
comme si je n'avais jamais vu un poil en
fait elodie dufau sa meuf je crois parce
que c'était parfois les gens ici et je
suis un peu perdue au coeur c'est moi tu
me parlais aga le monde est ici
influence a été client mais bon tu peux
le faire
sortons bull qui perd demain tu veux
bien tout ce qu'elle fait tu peux
m'abonner mais aussi pour moi je deviens
coin une vieille peau la danseuse étoile
c'est ça qu'on devient à 45 manière
générale c'est quoi ça me joue comme moi
ils veulent que je parte leur faim et
que certains disent que celle
influenceurs la normale vers le business
à peine au but c'est cool d'être à bout
bah je ne sens pas bien je vais faire du
mal qu'est ce qui se passe au spo
espagne à la fac je sais pas si j'ai
pris la bonne bourre est-ce que tu ma
gueule elle va jamais à l'école donc ça
y est j'ai un petit peu de succès tout
ça c'est quoi le problème on est passé
d' important pas d'accord avec elle
c'est ça mais ça va pas en quoi
[Applaudissements]
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
fais un gars plein de gens tout nus
moi je t'aime et je t'aimerai toujours
et cas je suis là depuis le début
c'est très bien se passer
[Musique]